I just did a survey around here to see
if the other guys I did want to be an
ass all about it but Ronnie the limo
driver just got new glasses and I think
he got the same ones I have pretty much
I mean maybe not the same brand but they
look identical and Nikki do I wear dark
glasses he's not wearing the dark
glasses everybody picked up on it okay
you got to admit those kind of do look
what I'm wearing you don't see that
similarity
look at him Robin Wow I noticed the
glasses the other day those he's wearing
sunglasses indoors no [ __ ] JD started
this whole stupid I saw it this morning
he started yes I'm in in the wrap-up
show waiting to go on they wanted this
is the first time I swear this morning I
didn't hear JD on about it I hope I saw
you this morning I'm not talking about
you yeah I'm talking about this [ __ ]
out there with his ten dollar Walgreens
glasses okay he started this [ __ ] at the
wrap-up show yesterday I'm sitting there
waiting to go on the rapper Shawn he's
like whispering to everybody now wearing
the dark glasses indoors like me I
always did no you did now you didn't
dude look at my other glasses the same
[ __ ] go outside and look at the picture
on the wall same thing right dude I
didn't are you joking me what do you
think a [ __ ] Sal now what are you
getting what do you get upset for I'm
not because I think it's stupid man okay
anything like you know it wasn't no no
[ __ ] JD with his ten [ __ ] dollar
Walgreens glasses he's breaking my balls
but anyway I listen I'm taking it as a
compliment I think you like my look and
you're very similar I didn't even think
about it okay no I saw your new glasses
so turn right at whoo doesn't look very
familiar like a borrowed I didn't even
think yeah you want to borrow muted
welcome to Bank your prize everyone out
the Hall said if you ask me about his
glasses he gets all upset
where's JD made a whole [ __ ] Farrow
project about it people want to know
it's really
do you make a whole federal project when
you get new glass get away from me with
those [ __ ] glasses you ass all and
why don't you get a new shirt already
been wearing f like three months or you
wear the same suit shirt what's going on
JT not bit I just I I was I am yesterday
to ask her about his new glasses cuz you
started it you want to just be a mr. mr.
[ __ ] producer over there no a glass
room you like its new glasses don't you
think they look like mine yeah I bet you
wish you had a pair reading glasses they
do like similar there are similarities
yeah and your point is what I just say
he he asked me and I answered the
question and what's the point though
that they're similar looking and saying
I copied them I dude I don't know I
don't know what goes on inside your head
at all going inside my head so what
happened when you when you saw his new
glasses you yeah well I had to see no
you know at the vibe partying here's
where
so what I was just wondering
that's it you're doing to make it a big
deal oh you make the big deal and
walking around told everybody about it
yesterday ronnie was in the hall
bragging that he spent 400 bucks
bragging oh yeah you did you say no my
glass is constant now it isn't
here's 400 you have to bring anything up
to begin with this [ __ ] [ __ ] by the
way with Ronnie's new glasses tell me he
doesn't look like Sal's dad I'm gonna do
close-up on Ronnie inside hey Ronnie
look forward same guy
this is goatee okay well guys Ronnie
congratulations on your name very much